digamos que aquí tenemos un circuito que
está conectado a una batería con voltaje
y tenemos los receptores 1 resistor 2 y
resistor 3 y hay corriente que fluye por
acá que tenemos que hacer si queremos
medir experimentalmente el voltaje que
pasa a través de algunos de estos
elementos pues tendremos que usar un
voltímetro el voltímetro lucia así es un
círculo con una uve adentro
ese es el símbolo que usamos para el
voltímetro como lo usamos pues tomamos
el voltímetro y todo los extremos del
voltímetro y los colocó a ambos lados
del elemento al cual quiero pedirle el
voltaje
hago esto conecto los extremos aquí y el
voltímetro me va decide el voltaje que
está pasando a través de la resistencia
a r3 o tomamos el voltímetro lo ponemos
por acá
y coloco los extremos alrededor de r1 en
paralelo noten que estoy conectando el
voltímetro en paralelo con el elemento
del cual quiero conocer su voltaje con
esto podré conocer cuál es el voltaje
que está pasando a través de la
resistencia a r 1 y si quiero ver que mi
batería está funcionando correctamente
tomo mi voltímetro y lo conecto a ambos
lados de la batería en las terminales
positiva y negativa de la batería y así
podré ver si la batería está funcionando
como debe y esa es la manera en la que
usamos el voltímetro siempre lo
conectamos en paralelo si yo quisiera
medir la corriente no voy a usar un
voltímetro voy a usar un amperímetro y
un amperímetro hamás lo conectamos en
paralelo si lo hacemos así lo más
probable es que quememos el amperímetro
ya lo he hecho un par de veces y no es
nada agradable así que nunca coloquen un
amperímetro en paralelo y en un momento
les voy a explicar por qué lo que
hacemos es conectarlo en
y si queremos conocer la corriente que
está pasando a través de r3 pongo este
amperímetro justo acá uno de los
extremos del amperímetro lo voy a
conectar aquí y el otro extremo lo voy a
conectar acá esto va a medir el flujo de
corriente que está pasando aquí que es
la corriente que está pasando por r3 no
importa de qué lado lo coloquemos la
corriente que entra por r3 va a ser
igual a la corriente que sale de r3 pero
tiene que conectarse en serie y es un
poco laborioso ya que tenemos que
desconectar algo del circuito para poder
colocar el amperímetro tenemos que
quitar algo del circuito para poder
conectar ambos extremos del amperímetro
en el para un voltímetro no tenemos que
hacer esto simplemente conectamos los
extremos en ambos lados del elemento al
que le queremos medir el voltaje pero
para un amperímetro tenemos que abrir el
circuito de manera que podamos conectar
ambos extremos del amperímetro en este
circuito si lo pongo aquí me va a decir
la cantidad de corriente que pasa por
esta sección
recuerden que los amperímetro siempre se
conectan en serie con el elemento al
cual le queremos medir la corriente si
pongo aquí el amperímetro me va a
indicar cuál es la corriente que está
pasando por la batería pero porque el
voltímetro siempre se conecta en
paralelo y el amperímetro siempre se
conecta en serie
queremos que el amperímetro esté
conectado en serie porque queremos
conocer la corriente que está pasando a
través de un segmento del circuito si
queremos conocer la corriente que está
pasando a través de este resistor tengo
que asegurarme que esa corriente esté
pasando a través de mi amperímetro y es
por eso que las personas diseñan los and
perímetros con muy poca resistencia el
amperímetro tiene muy poca resistencia
la razón es que si tenemos este
amperímetro con una gran resistencia y
lo colocamos aquí no estaremos cambiando
la cantidad de corriente que está
pasando por el circuito cada vez que
queremos medir algo no queremos
perturbar lo por lo que cuando pongo mi
amperímetro aquí no quiero afectar mi
circuito
quiero conocer cuánta corriente pasa por
acá sin que esté el amperímetro ahí por
lo que si pongo mi amperímetro acá debe
tener un efecto muy pequeño en el
comportamiento del circuito es por eso
que los perímetros tienen una
resistencia muy muy pequeña y esa es la
razón por la que no podemos conectar un
amperímetro en paralelo ya que si lo
hacemos lo que sucede esto está mal si
yo conecto esté amperímetro aquí y el
otro lado lo pongo acá la corriente va a
pasar por acá la corriente llega a esta
bifurcación y tiene que decidir si va a
fluir hacia la izquierda o hacia la
derecha en un lado tengo a r3 y en el
otro lado tengo a mi amperímetro que
casi no tiene resistencia y esta
resistencia es de verdad pequeña quizás
en el orden de los 1000 oms por lo que
toda la corriente se va a ir por acá
donde hay menos resistencia no va a
pasar por estos otros resistor es sino
que todas se va a ir hacia el
amperímetro y si tenemos un voltaje
normal digamos de 9 volts
3 volts conectado a un million vamos a
quemar al amperímetro normalmente los
amperímetro tienen un fusible ya que
saben que con seguridad nos vamos a
equivocar y los vamos a conectar en
paralelo por lo que se va a quemar el
fusible y vamos a tener que reemplazarlo
y es algo bastante latoso así que mejor
evitemos lo nunca conecten su
amperímetro en paralelo y qué pasa con
los multímetros qué pasa si los
conectamos en paralelo no conectamos un
voltímetro en paralelo porque queremos
conocer el voltaje que pasa en ambos
lados de ese elemento recuerden que el
voltaje se define como la diferencia en
el potencial eléctrico entre dos puntos
en el espacio por lo que no tiene caso
preguntarnos cuál es el voltaje a través
de cierta parte del circuito tenemos
corriente que pasa por esa parte del
circuito pero al preguntarnos cuál es el
voltaje en cierta parte del circuito no
tiene sentido lo que tiene sentido es
preguntarnos cuál es el voltaje entre
dos puntos del circuito
puedo preguntarme cuál es el voltaje
entre este punto y este otro punto o
puedo preguntarme cuál es el voltaje que
hay entre este punto y este otro punto
esto tiene sentido pero preguntarnos el
voltaje en un solo punto del circuito no
lo tiene
la corriente pasa por un punto el
voltaje es la diferencia de potencial
eléctrico entre dos puntos y es por eso
que conectamos los voltímetros en
paralelo y debido a que conectamos los
multímetros en paralelo los voltímetros
deben de tener una gran resistencia
algunas veces en el orden de cientos de
miles de homs o incluso millones de homs
esa es una resistencia enorme y la razón
de esto es que nuevamente la idea es que
no queremos afectar el comportamiento
del circuito como esta no quiero afectar
lo que quiero medir estoy midiendo el
voltaje que hay en este resistor
si yo coloca aquí un voltímetro con una
resistencia muy pequeña ya vimos qué es
lo que sucede toda la corriente que sale
de la batería va a pasar por donde hay
menos resistencia por
tratará de pasar todas en este
voltímetro y no solo me va a echar a
perder mi voltímetro esta corriente ya
no estará pasando a través de r3 por lo
que no voy a tener una medición correcta
del voltaje en este elemento queremos
asegurarnos de que el voltímetro tenga
una gran resistencia y bueno es posible
que una pequeña cantidad de corriente
quizás un 1000 jumper puede estar
pasando a través del voltímetro ya que
tiene que tomar la lectura pero queremos
que esta corriente sea lo más pequeña
posible ya que queremos que esta
corriente pase por r3 de la misma forma
que lo haría si no tuviéramos conectado
el voltímetro ya que b es igual a iu por
r si puedo medir este voltaje quiero
asegurarme de que la corriente sea la
misma o no obtendré una medición
correcta del voltaje y ustedes se pueden
preguntar qué pasaría si yo conectar el
voltímetro en serie en lugar de
conectarlo en paralelo bueno los
voltímetros tienen una resistencia
enorme por lo que si lo coloco aquí con
esta resistencia enorme no le va a pasar
nadal voltímetro pero la corriente ya no
va a querer pasar por ahí la corriente
que sale de esta batería tiene una
opción irse por acá o por acá por r3 y
el voltímetro o por r1 y r2 y dijimos
que el voltímetro tiene cientos de miles
o incluso millones de ons así que la
corriente ni de chiste va a pasar por
este lugar con tanta resistencia
así que si conectamos un multímetro en
serie en lugar de en paralelo vamos a
evitar que cualquier corriente pase por
este segmento del circuito aunque
probablemente al voltímetro no le pase
nada no es tan delicado como el
amperímetro pero aún así vamos a afectar
nuestras mediciones así que recuerden
que los voltímetro se conectan en
paralelo al elemento del cual queremos
medir le el voltaje y los amperímetro se
conectan en serie al elemento del cual
queremos medir la corriente y aunque
ustedes digan o no yo nunca voy a
conectar mi amperímetro en paralelo no
soy tan tonto
bueno tienen que tener cuidado de todas
maneras ya que la mayoría de los
multímetros son tanto en perímetros como
voltímetros dependiendo de hacia donde
apunte el dial así que si ustedes están
sentados todo el día midiendo corriente
con la configuración en amperímetro con
el dial en amperímetro todo va a ir muy
bien y de repente tienen que medir un
voltaje pero se les olvida cambiar el
dial hacia la posición de voltímetro y
se queden amperímetro estarán conectando
un amperímetro en paralelo de forma
incorrecta y eso es lo que me pasó a mí
no dejen que esto les pasa a ustedes
siempre verifiquen el dial en su
multímetro y asegúrense de que está en
la función que ustedes quieren usar para
que no quede ningún fusible